so sydney powell has filed a motion to
dismiss the multi-billion dollar lawsuit
filed by dominion and yes the headlines
are true
her principal defense in this motion to
dismiss
is that no reasonable person would
listen to the things that she said
and understand it as a fact now that is
both
true and hilarious but probably not
hilarious for the reasons that most
pundits have
discussed but we'll get to that because
this whole motion
is ridiculous
[Music]
so welcome back to kraken watch 2021
and today we have sidney powell's
attempt to get out of the multi-billion
dollar lawsuit that dominion filed
to bring you up to speed dominion claims
that sydney powell
said all number of crazy things during
the election and as a result
they lost a huge amount of money and as
a result they have sued sydney powell
for
defamation so first off where are we
well this is a motion to dismiss so if
you are a defendant in a case
you can claim that the plaintiff's case
is legally deficient
by filing what's called a motion to
dismiss you ask the court to
dismiss the case now contrary to popular
belief as we've talked about a lot on
this channel emotion to dismiss
doesn't present any evidence all you're
doing is saying that
for the purposes of this motion
everything that the plaintiff claims
in their complaint is understood as true
they're not conceding that but they're
saying
look we're not going to dispute the
facts at this particular juncture we're
just going to assume that that's true
and even
assuming that everything is true and
looking at the allegations of the light
most favorable to the plaintiff
it still fails right out of the gate now
this is a very common tactic there are
later motions that you can make that
will incorporate evidence but the idea
is to try and get rid of the case
immediately before going through very
expensive discovery that will gather
all of that evidence now in addition to
trying to just dismiss the case outright
they're also moving for a whole bunch of
other things like
moving the venue from washington dc to
texas
and a bunch of other things that we're
not going to get into because the real
heart of this motion is
trying to dismiss it from the court and
not having to deal with it anymore at
all
and a quick reminder defamation is a
tort where you claim that someone said
something factual about you that is
untrue and that caused damages to you
and your reputations
of course that requires that the things
being said are factual being capable of
verification
and are not someone's opinion uh it's
not hyperbole it's not
parody and so you can imagine that a lot
of the suit hinges on
the nature of the statements at issue
here and right off the bat sydney powell
and her attorneys try and argue some
things to tip things in their favor
the first argument is that of course
this whole affair involved political
speech an election a president being
elected a
fiercely contested election in a
pandemic and as you can imagine free
speech rights are at their absolute
pinnacle when you're talking about
political speech
so if the court were to err on one side
it should be allowing more political or
arguably political speech
than stifling it and then number two is
that dominion
is a public figure and if dominion is a
public figure
they're subject to a much higher
requirement to be able to prove
defamation this is the actual malice
standard that
a lot of people have talked about in a
defamation context and i don't want to
beat a dead horse here
but i will say this every time we talk
about defamation law
actual malice doesn't mean that you said
a statement because you hated someone
actual malice means that you said a
statement that was false
knowing it was false or operating in a
reckless disregard for whether
it was true or not and if dominion is a
public figure or a limited purpose
public figure with respect to election
related things
then it would have to prove that sydney
powell said these statements uh
with actual malice which is a pretty
high burden and fair enough as we
covered on this very channel
sydney powell might be right about this
and dominion faces an uphill battle to
be able to prove the allegations
that they included in their complaint
but that's
where this motion to dismiss starts to
go off the rails because
now sydney powell starts arguing
substantively
that these statements that she made the
hundreds of them
cannot give rise to defamation and
here's where things
get a little bit ridiculous and then
sidney powell goes
straight to the heart of it and argues
analyzed under these facts even assuming
arguendo that each of the statements
alleged in the complaint could be proved
true or false
no reasonable person would conclude that
the statements were truly statements of
fact and there are lots of people on the
internet taking that statement and
saying that sydney powell has admitted
that everything that she said was
completely
false and admits that she's a liar
not so fast though the things that she's
arguing are pretty crazy
that's not one of them that is
technically a defense to defamation to
say that
the things that you're saying are not
statements of fact
what she's hearkening back to is the
idea that what she is saying
is opinion there are lots of facts out
there and then she just
interprets them and that interpretation
is not a statement of fact that can give
rise to
defamation this is not a bad strategy it
is a bit of a mea culpa
it's not a good strategy but it's
probably the best strategy that she has
in this context and it's not a
straight-up admission that everything
that she says
was false in fact later in the motion
they say that sydney powell actually
does
believe these things they are sort of
arguing that no reasonable person would
believe them
but also that she does believe them but
we'll get to that in a second because
it's just crazy the other thing that
she's sort of arguing here
is the idea that you can sometimes say
things that would give rise to
defamation as a
fact but given the context of the
situation
it sort of walks it back and the famous
example of this is the fake letter
written by jerry falwell that appeared
in hustler magazine where this
putative jerry falwell talked about
losing his virginity and all kinds of
raunchy things in hustler magazine
it was clearly satire and parody and
even though these were things that were
sort of alleged as being true these were
factual statements
the context made it clear that no one
would understand these to be
actual allegations about jerry falwell
now ironically
the context may not actually help sydney
powell in this case
because not only is she saying all of
these things on tv
on fox news at the rnc where she argues
that it's clearly just political theater
but she's also making these exact same
arguments in front
of judges she filed numerous lawsuits
contending that these things were
actual facts so sydney powell finds
herself on the horns of a dilemma here
because on the one hand she's arguing
these aren't factual statements they're
more akin to an interpretation or an
opinion
especially given the context but then on
the other
she's actually making these arguments to
judges she wanted the courts to actually
intervene
and grant temporary restraining orders
preliminary injunctions
relief to overturn the elections on the
basis of the things that she's saying
here
there might be ways to thread this
needle but this ain't it chief
now unfortunately there are some
practical reasons why
a lawyer might dissemble or at least say
different things in different contexts
and that's that
it's really hard to sanction a lawyer
judges hate sanctioning lawyers bar
associations hate sanctioning lawyers so
if you're going to claim
that the things that you were saying
were complete nonsense
better to say that in defense of a
defamation case where
you have millions of dollars at stake
and just try and roll the dice with
respect to
being sanctioned by the courts that
you're appearing of now the irony here
is that there are pending sanctions
motions against
sydney powell and the things that she is
arguing
in this briefing may hurt her in those
sanctions context
it now the dollar amounts are not going
to be the same uh but
potentially theoretically her bar
license might be
at issue in some of these cases though i
wouldn't hold my breath
because judges hate to sanction lawyers
just like lawyers hate to sanction
lawyers
though at the same time it is baked
right into legal ethics
that you cannot knowingly lie or
dissemble
to a judge or tribunal it's all over the
ethical rules for lawyers in every
single state
and she's running a really really fine
line here
and i would not want to be in her
position and on the one hand she's
arguing that no reasonable person would
believe any of these things
and yet she made these arguments to
judges and
tried to argue them in front of juries
in a way to get them to believe
these things and of course we know that
a lot of people believed the things that
she was saying there were
thousands of people in washington dc who
stormed the capitol
i was here i can attest to it and so
uh hard to say that no reasonable person
would believe it
because a lot of people believed it now
of course query whether the people that
stormed the capital were reasonable
people or not that's not
the way that the reasonable person
standard works but still
it's probably pretty good evidence that
people believed what she was saying
enough to act on it and i wouldn't want
to be in her position in trying to walk
that back and saying it was so
ridiculous and non-factual that no one
would believe it
but look she has grifted a whole lot of
people out of a whole lot of money
by saying dumber things than that the
dominion operators
went in and injected votes and changed
the whole system
and perhaps the biggest irony here is
that she's arguing that as
an attorney as an advocate as a zealous
advocate in front of a court
you have to do what's right by your
client but that cannot mean
that you can just make stuff up and
fabricate arguments that
that's not the way legal ethics work and
it's at this point in the brief
where basically powell's legal team
stops citing actual legal authority
and they start just citing websites now
that's really bad for two reasons number
one emotion to dismiss is all about the
law
itself for the most part and you can't
really bring in
new evidence even if it's not
necessarily controverted
so trying to bring in these external
websites talking about the robust public
discussion not a good look and it's
almost certain that the court will
bounce this motion on that basis alone
which takes us to the arguments about
actual malice and recall that actual
mouse is a high standard
and it all hinges on what the alleged
defamer was thinking
did they know the things that they were
saying were false did they know
or should they have known was were they
reckless with respect to whether it was
true or
false and sydney powell tries to get
around that and get this case dismissed
on the basis that she had a true belief
that the things that she was saying were
true
and factual and so she's arguing that
she couldn't possibly have had actual
malice with respect to these
false statements because she really
believed him so yes
she is arguing that no reasonable person
would believe that these were factual
statements and at the same time she is
arguing that she
did actually believe the things that she
was saying
it's crazy president trump won by a
landslide
we are going to prove it and we are
going to reclaim the united states of
america for the
people who vote for freedom then as we
round out this motion we get to another
argument to dismiss a co-defendant
called dtr defending the republic
and in something that i think is just
funny as a practicing lawyer
you'll notice that there are some
formatting errors here
the font has changed colors sometimes it
changes back
what that is indicative of is when
lawyers copy and paste from another
brief
and then forgets that sometimes external
documents are in a different color often
it's dark blue
and so that's almost always why a
different section has a different
uh font color and appears a little bit
lighter and it's it varies depending on
the sentence
it's because they did a really sloppy
job of copying and pasting now copying
and pasting isn't the end of the world
lawyers are allowed to do that
and you know you shouldn't necessarily
reinvent the wheel
but it's uh it's it's a real bad look
when it's very clear that you're copying
from
some other brief and not even bothering
to change the formatting
so this motion is risable the court is
almost certainly going to deny
this motion there's a better version of
this motion that could have been made
but you know you play the hand that
you're dealt i suppose and
a lot of people are dog piling on this
saying that sydney powell admitted that
she was a liar
it doesn't go that far she does argue
extremely contradictory things that are
going to hurt her case it's going to
hurt her in other contexts where she
might have to deal with
sanctions but uh we don't need to
make up additional reasons for why this
is a bad look
and why she's crazy because she's crazy
enough on her own
but what do you think do you agree with
my analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all my other real law
reviews where i have talked about kraken
law at nauseum
so check out these other videos and i
will see you in court